una explosión desgarra las calles
desiertas del isi chance que la ciudad
aún sigue bajo control ucraniano pero
las tropas rusas están intensificando
sus bombardeos conforme se van acercando
en un bosque cercano estos soldados
ucranianos siguen contra atacando con
armamentos muy antiguos
este sistema tiene 16 cohetes desde 1986
tienen 26 pierce auto
a unos 10 kilómetros de distancia severo
donges que está casi totalmente en manos
rusas solo la zona industrial la planta
de azote aún resiste un lugar donde
también se esconden cientos de civiles
las fuerzas prorrusas confían en la
victoria
y es que mi puesto en severodonezk
estamos muy cerca de la planta química
de asad
lo que significa que estamos terminando
la batalla en la zona industrial
[Música]
aún así las tropas ucranianas siguen
dando batalla un grupo de refuerzos fue
filmado cruzando a la ciudad en barco
durante el fin de semana ya que todos
los puentes hacia severodonezk fueron
destruidos los combatientes pero rusos
admiten que el avance no ha sido fácil
la situación aquí sigue siendo tensa el
ejército ucraniano sigue disparando
sobre esta zona y colocando minas a
distancia para dificultar nuestros
movimientos
si severodonezk y visitantes caen rusia
tendría el control total de la región de
lugansk un paso más cerca de su objetivo
de hacerse con la totalidad del donbass